élever nos enfants
et ne plus nous soucier des choses liées à ton handicap. »
Je n'ai pas cru mon père, non parce qu'il était un menteur,
mais parce que je découvrais cette histoire,
et en fait, l'idée avait plu à ma mère.
Elle ne me l'avait jamais dit.
Mais en réalité, je ne sais pas pourquoi cette histoire m'a surprise,
puisque quand j'avais cinq ans,
et que ma mère, comme tous les parents des États-Unis,
m'a emmenée à l'école pour m'inscrire,
elle m'a poussée vers l'école, à quelques pas de notre maison,
elle m'a tirée en haut des escaliers,
et le directeur nous a accueillies.
Enfin, pas vraiment.
Il disait que l'école ne pouvait pas m'accueillir
car elle était inaccessible.
Mais il nous a dit de ne pas nous inquiéter,
car le conseil d'établissement allait m'envoyer un professeur.
Et ils l'ont fait
pour seulement deux heures et demie
par semaine.
(Murmures du public)
Mais grâce à ma bonne conduite,
ils m'ont envoyé un thérapeute de métier
qui m'a enseigné une compétence très importante :
la broderie au point de croix.
(Rires)
Je n'en fais plus.
En fait, pour aller dans une vraie école,
j'ai attendu d'avoir neuf ans,
puis je n'ai fréquenté que des classes avec des élèves handicapés
dans une école où ils étaient minoritaires.
Et dans les classes que je fréquentais,
les élèves les plus âgés avaient 21 ans.
Puis, on les envoyait dans des ateliers protégés,
pour faire des tâches subalternes,
et ils ne gagnaient rien, sinon moins que le minimum légal.
C'est ainsi que j'ai compris ce qu'était la discrimination.
Mes parents l'avaient compris eux aussi.
Ils venaient d'Allemagne.
Ils étaient des Juifs allemands qui s'étaient exilés dans les années 30,
fuyant l'Holocauste.
Ils avaient perdu de la famille et des parents.
Leurs parents sont morts durant l'Holocauste.
Ils ont constaté
qu'ils ne pouvaient se taire
alors que ça allait mal dans ma vie.
Pas moi personnellement,
mais ce qui se passait autour de moi.
Comme je me déplaçais en fauteuil roulant,
ils ont appris qu'aucun lycée n'était accessible à New York
donc voilà ce qui m'attendait :
je devais reprendre les cours à domicile
comme de nombreux élèves.
Mes parents se sont associés à d'autres parents.
Ils sont allés au conseil d'établissement
pour leur demander de rendre accessible des lycées.
Et ils y sont parvenus.
Ainsi, j'ai pu, comme de nombreux élèves,
aller au lycée, dans un lycée normal,
et suivre des cours normaux.
Que s'est-il passé ensuite ?
J'approfondissais mes connaissances sur les discriminations,
et, fait aussi important, j'apprenais que je devais me défendre.
Je venais de m'inscrire à l'université de Long Island,
et depuis toujours, je voulais être enseignante,
j'ai choisi enseignement en sous-dominante et j'ai suivi tous les cours appropriés,
puis, afin d'obtenir ma licence,
je devais passer un examen écrit,
un examen oral
et un examen médical.
À l'époque, ces trois examens avaient lieu
dans des bâtiments totalement inaccessibles,
donc mes amis me portaient afin de monter et descendre les marches
pour ces examens,
pas dans un fauteuil roulant électrique.
(Rires)
Dans un fauteuil roulant manuel.
Mais j'ai réussi l'oral.
J'ai réussi l'écrit.
Ça a été totalement différent pour l'examen médical.
L'une des premières questions que m'a posées le docteur fut :
« Est-ce que je pouvais lui montrer comment j'allais aux toilettes ? »
J'avais 22 ans
et lorsque vous allez dans ce genre d'entretiens,
vous pensez aux questions qu'on vous posera.
(Rires)
Mais ce n'en était pas une.
Et j'ai été déboussolée au début
puisque j'avais entendu dire
qu'aucune personne en fauteuil roulant
n'enseignait à New York,
je m'attendais constamment au pire.
Je lui ai répondu :
« Les enseignants doivent-ils montrer à leurs étudiants
comment aller aux toilettes ?
Si c'est le cas, je peux le faire. »
Donc sans surprise,
j'ai échoué
car je n'avais pas réussi le test médical.
Officiellement, je n'avais pas eu le poste
à cause d'une paralysie de poliomyélite, séquelles de... je suis désolée.
Paralysie des deux membres inférieurs, séquelles de la poliomyélite.
J'ignorais honnêtement le sens du mot « séquelles »,
j'ai donc consulté le dictionnaire, qui indiquait « à cause de ».
Je n'avais pas eu ma licence car je ne pouvais pas marcher.
Qu'allais-je donc faire ?
C'est un moment très important de ma vie,
car c'était la première fois
que j'allais réellement défier le système,
et bien que je travaillais avec beaucoup d'amis handicapés
qui m'incitaient à surmonter tout cela,
c'était néanmoins assez effrayant.
Mais j'ai vraiment eu de la chance.
J'avais un ami handicapé, étudiant à l'université de Long Island
mais aussi pigiste au New York Times.
Grâce à lui, un journaliste a écrit un très bon article
dans lequel il racontait ce qui s'était passé
et expliquait pourquoi c'était injuste.
Le lendemain, le New York Times publiait un éditorial.
Son titre était : « Heumann contre le conseil d'établissement »
et le New York Times m'a soutenue
afin que je j'obtienne ma licence d'enseignement.
(Applaudissements)
Et le jour même,
j'ai reçu l'appel d'un avocat qui écrivait un livre sur les droits civiques.
Il voulait une interview
mais ce fut moi qui l'interviewai.
Il ne le réalisait pas.
Puis à la fin de la discussion, j'ai dit :
« Pourriez-vous me représenter face au conseil d'établissement ? »
Et il m'a dit oui.
Parfois, je me dis que pour ce procès, les étoiles étaient bien alignées
puisque qu'on avait une juge incroyable :
la première juge fédérale Afro-Américaine
(Rires)
Constance Baker Motley.
(Applaudissements)
Et elle reconnaissait la discrimination lorsqu'elle y était confrontée.
(Rires)
Elle a donc vivement incité le conseil d'établissement
à me faire passer un autre examen médical,
ce qu'ils ont fait.
Puis j'ai obtenu ma licence,
et même s'il a fallu plusieurs mois
pour recevoir une proposition d'un directeur d'établissement,
j'ai finalement obtenu un poste et j'ai enseigné dès cet automne-là
dans la même école où j'avais été,
en classe de CE1.
Donc
(Applaudissements)
C'est une autre conférence TED.
(Rires)
Mais j'apprenais tout comme mes amis
et d'autres gens à travers le pays,
que nous devions nous défendre nous-mêmes,
et combattre les idées reçues
selon lesquelles il fallait guérir les personnes handicapées
et selon lesquelles l'égalité était un sujet secondaire.
Et nous apprenions du Mouvement des droits civiques
et du Mouvement des droits des femmes.
Nous nous intéressions à leur activisme
et à leur capacité à se réunir,
non seulement pour traiter des problèmes
mais aussi pour proposer des solutions.
Et cela a donné le Mouvement des droits des personnes handicapées.
J'aimerais vous poser quelques devinettes.
Selon vous, combien de gens faut-il
pour bloquer la circulation sur Madison Avenue
lors des heures de pointe à New York ?
Une estimation ? Combien ?
(Des personnes du public répondent)
Cinquante.
Une, ce serait insuffisant.
Cinquante personnes.
Et les fourgons de police étaient inaccessibles,
donc ils n'avaient qu'à s'occuper de nous.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais laissez-moi vous poser une autre devinette.
Combien de personnes faut-il pour arrêter un bus à New York
quand on refuse de vous laisser entrer à cause de votre fauteuil roulant ?
Une seule. C'est la bonne réponse.
Voici ce qu'il faut faire :
vous faites avancer le fauteuil roulant,
(Rires)
vous vous faufilez au bon endroit, juste en face des marches,
vous le poussez un peu en dessous,
et leur bus ne peut plus bouger.
(Rires)
Si quelqu'un veut apprendre à faire cela,
qu'il m'en parle après.
(Rires)
En 1972, le Président Nixon a mis son veto à la loi relative à la réadaptation.
Nous avons protesté. Il l'a signée.
Mais les réglementations à promulguer pour appliquer la loi
n'avaient pas été signées, en réalité.
Nous avons manifesté. Elles ont été signées.
Alors que la loi relative aux Américains handicapés (ADA),
notre Proclamation d'émancipation,
risquait d'être rejetée par une des chambres du Congrès,
des personnes handicapées des États-Unis se sont rassemblées
et ont rampé sur les marches du Capitole.
Ce futt une journée incroyable,
et le Congrès a adopté l'ADA.
Puis le Président Bush a signé l'ADA.
C'est une belle photo.
Le Président Bush a signé l'ADA sur la pelouse de la Maison Blanche.
Ce fut une journée incroyable,
et il y avait environ 2 000 personnes.
C'était le 26 juillet 1990.
Et durant son discours, il a fait cette célèbre déclaration :
« Laissons les murs honteux de l'exclusion s'effondrer définitivement. »
Les personnes dans cette salle
qui ont au moins 50 ans, voire 40 ans ou plus,
se souviennent d'une époque où les rues n'avaient pas de rampes,
où les bus étaient inaccessibles,
ainsi que les trains,
et les toilettes des centres commerciaux,
Il n'existait même pas d'interprètes en langue des signes,
et on avait ni sous-titres, ni braille, ni aucune autre forme d'adaptation.
Les choses ont changé,
et le monde s'en est inspiré.
Ailleurs, la même législation est réclamée par des personnes handicapées,
et elles veulent la renforcer.
Cela a abouti à quelque chose :
la Convention relative aux droits des personnes handicapées.
C'est un traité adopté en 2006.
Il célèbre son dixième anniversaire.
Plus de 165 pays ont rejoint ce traité.
C'est le premier traité international sur les droits humains
qui concerne uniquement les personnes handicapées.
Mais j'ai le regret de dire que notre Sénat
n'a pas su convaincre notre président de le ratifier.
Nous l'avons signé en 2009,
mais sans ratification, il ne peut entrer en vigueur
et un président ne peut ratifier un traité
sans le consentement du Sénat.
Nous sommes donc fortement convaincus
que notre Sénat doit faire son travail,
qu'en tant qu'Américains, notre Sénat doit nous permettre
d'intéresser les personnes handicapées et les gouvernements du monde entier
au travail remarquable que nous faisons,
mais il est également important
que les personnes handicapées aient autant d'opportunités
de voyager, étudier, et travailler à l'étranger
que les autres personnes de notre pays.
Tant que de nombreux pays n'imiteront pas notre législation
ou ne l'appliqueront pas,
cela limitera les opportunités pour les personnes handicapées.
À chaque fois que je vais à l'étranger,
je rencontre des femmes handicapées,
elles me racontent des histoires
sur les violences et les viols qu'elles subissent
et m'expliquent que souvent,
ces violences proviennent de parents ou de connaissances,
qui peuvent même travailler pour elles.
Souvent, ces affaires ne sont pas jugées.
Je rencontre des personnes handicapées
qui ont reçu des offres d'emplois de la part d'entreprises
car elles vivent dans des pays où il existe un système de quota,
et pour éviter de recevoir des amendes,
ces entreprises vous recruteront
et vous diront :
« Vous pouvez rester chez vous,
nous n'avons pas besoin de vous dans l'entreprise. »
J'ai visité des foyers
qu'avant d'ouvrir la porte de votre voiture,
vous êtes comme repoussé.
J'ai aussi été dans ces foyers
où des gens devraient vivre en communauté avec les moyens appropriés
et j'ai vu des gens presque nus,
des gens drogués chimiquement
et des gens vivant dans le désespoir.
Les États-Unis doivent faire davantage pour améliorer cela.
Nous savons reconnaître la discrimination lorsque nous la voyons,
et nous devons la combattre ensemble.
Que pouvons-nous donc faire ensemble ?
Vous devez tous reconnaître
que le handicap est une famille que vous pouvez rejoindre un jour.
J'aimerais que vous leviez la main : combien se sont déjà cassé quelque chose ?
Eh bien, quand vous partirez ce soir, j'aimerais que vous écriviez
ce que vous avez ressenti durant cette période,
car souvent, j'entends des personnes dire :
« Vous savez, je ne pouvais pas faire ceci ou cela.
On me parlait autrement. On agissait autrement avec moi. »
Et c'est ce que les personnes handicapées comme moi constatent
en substance.
Mais nous -- vous dans cette salle,
les personnes qui écoutent et regardent cette conférence TED,
ensemble, nous pouvons faire bouger les choses.
Ensemble, nous pouvons nous battre pour la justice.
Ensemble, nous pouvons changer le monde.
Merci. Je dois aller prendre mon bus.
(Applaudissements)